Transcriptor: Julio Delgadillo
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Mira a la mujer que tienes a un lado,
a la que te acompaña hoy.
¿Podrías decir que solamente
con verla a los ojos es una mujer feliz?
En el 2014, según datos del INEGI,
solamente el 56 % de las mujeres mexicanas
se sienten felices.
Yo formo parte de un grupo de 4500
mujeres que radicamos en San Luis Potosí
o somos originarias de esta ciudad, todas
somos muy diferentes, tenemos diferencias
desde el largo de nuestro cabello,
la zona en la ciudad en la que
vivimos, la religión que profesamos,
el número de hijos que tenemos,
la forma en que los educamos, unas optan
por la disciplina positiva y otras todavía
confían en el poder de la chancla.
Habemos solteras, casadas, abuelas,
chaparritas, delgaditas,
las que creen que las quesadillas solo
son de queso y las que tenemos la razón.
En nuestro grupo, todas somos diferentes,
y es cierto, hay un dicho popular
que dice: "mujeres juntas, ni difuntas".
¿Andarán dos juntas
si no estuvieran de acuerdo?
Nosotras, a pesar de las diferencias,
cuando se trata de un bien común,
las 4500 mujeres que somos
hoy, somos una sola.
Todos los días hacemos diferentes
actividades de manera virtual y física
que buscan que todas las mujeres que
forman parte de nuestra comunidad
se sepan amadas, respetadas, valoradas,
seguras, valientes, capaces, que nada
ni nadie las puede detener.
Actividades virtuales tan simples como
contestar una encuesta para saber cuál
es tu sabor favorito del helado, compartir
un pedacito de la gran historia que tienes
de vida por qué de este modo seguramente
habrá una desconocida que pueda
identificarse contigo.
Contar cómo fue una experiencia de tus
hijos, sentirte contenta por el nacimiento
de un bebé, sentir que te gradúas con
la que vive enfrente, cosas tan sencillas
como transmisiones en vivo con expertas
que nos hablan desde mecánica,
salud mental, disciplina positiva,
entre muchas otras cosas... y actividades
físicas que pueden ir desde un simple
desayuno con la vecina que aún no conoces
pero forma parte de esta comunidad
hasta fiestas, clubes de lectura, tejido,
carreras, muchísimas cosas pero nuestro
más grande motor son las causas benéficas.
El libro con más traducciones y más
vendido en la historia mundial no nos
deja opciones, nos dice: "Ama a tu prójimo
como a ti mismo, ve por la viuda, aboga
por el huérfano, no angusties
al extranjero, acuérdate de los presos
como si estuvieras juntamente con ellos".
Es por eso que nosotras no tenemos opción,
lo hemos tomado como nuestro deber y como
una obligación; de ésta forma nos hemos
involucrado con la Casa del Migrante,
asilos de ancianos, casas hogar,
el albergue del Hospital Central, el
Instituto para Ciegos y Débiles Visuales
del Estado entre muchas otras
Instituciones como aquéllas que
trabajan con mujeres que son
violentadas y sus familias.
Realizamos un proceso cada tres meses
que inicia eligiendo a una Institución,
Asociación o grupo vulnerable de nuestra
ciudad, esto para entregarles una donación
en especie haciendo un proceso que
durará un mes completo.
Iniciando con la sensibilización de
nuestras miembros para que conozcan
un poco de las personas que la Institución
que hemos elegido está atendiendo.
Una de las más difíciles ha sido que
nuestras mujeres vean a las que están
reclusas como lo que son, mujeres que
tienen necesidades tan básicas como
tú o como yo, de usar un jabón o
una muda limpia.
Lo mismo ha sucedido para entender
un poco de las dificultades
que viven los ciegos
en las calles de nuestra ciudad
entender que los migrantes a veces solo
viajan con lo puesto y nada más.
Después de la sensibilización de conocer
un poco la Institución y sus directivos,
comenzamos lanzando retos a
nuestras miembros en diferentes zonas
de la ciudad, son retos muy sencillos.
Por ejemplo si tú, mujer de nuestro grupo
estás perdidamente enamorada de Thor,
entonces tendrás que donar una bolsa
de arroz, si por el contrario
estás perdidamente enamorada de Ironman,
todas hagan: aaaaahh,
los caballeros se pueden abstener...
Entonces deberás donar una presentación
en tetrapak de puré condimentado.
Así de sencillo, y entonces generamos
un sentido de competencia pero de unión
entre una zona de la ciudad y la otra.
El norte contra el sur,
el este contra el oeste,
pero todas donando para una misma causa.
No importa si vives en Lomas
o si vives en Pozos, todas vamos a
colaborar hacia la misma causa.
Posteriormente, realizamos
un picnic familiar en el que todos,
tanto las mujeres, los hijos y los esposos
se involucran de la misma manera.
Los retos pueden ser llevados también
por ellos.
En este reto de los súper héroes
también invitamos a las mujeres
a que se disfrazaran,
es probable que hayan robado
la máscara de Ironman de uno de
sus hijos o que hayan tomado
un mandil de la cocina para elaborar
su capa; cosas así de simples.
Los esposos son quiénes
les toman la foto como evidencia de que
están cumpliendo con sus retos y
durante el picnic los donativos
que hayamos juntado
se clasifican, se separan, se contabilizan
para que ese mismo día se entreguen
a la Institución. Hemos entregado
en nuestra última causa un camión de
3.5 toneladas para una sola casa hogar
apoyando nosotros a dos, entregando
equitativamente para ambas casas.
Además, realizamos subastas. Las subastas
las llevamos a cabo por parte de quiénes
dirigimos el grupo, cuando escuchamos
el concepto "subasta a beneficio de",
probablemente lo primero que te venga en
mente sea una noche elegante,
la gente usando ropa muy fina, pujando
para adquirir obras de arte reconocidas
o piezas de joyería muy fina.
Nosotras realizamos nuestras subastas
a cara lavada y con nuestra mejor pijama.
De tal modo que tomamos donaciones de
nuestras miembros para realizar subastas
en cosas muy simples, puede ser quizá
un pay de queso hecho en casa o
un servicio de auto lavado, supongamos que
tomamos el pay de queso con un costo de
100 pesos, comenzaremos la puja
en 50 pesos y así iremos subiendo,
el reto consiste, para quiénes dirigimos
el grupo, es que si de esos 50 pesos
llegamos a 100, que es el costo original,
nosotras cumpliremos un reto
como pegar nuestra cara en el vidrio.
Si rebasamos ese costo, entonces
podremos hacer una danza africana
aunque no tengamos ni la más
remota idea de como se realiza...
Y si duplicamos el precio, entonces
hablaremos por un buen rato
con el efecto que produce tragar helio
de un globo metálico.
De esta forma, así tan sencillo, nuestras
amigas donan, pagan y apoyamos
una institución, por no decir que pagan
por vernos hacer el ridículo.
Gracias a este tipo de cosas,
en este reto recaudamos en 15 minutos
2000 pesos para el albergue del Hospital
Central, en este tipo de retos,
nos ha permitido adquirir regletas y
bastones para los alumnos del Insituto
para Ciegos y Débiles Visuales.
Adquirimos 80 piezas de mudas y sandalias
para las reclusas en La Pila, además de
entregar las sandalias para los reos que
son Adultos Mayores y los que son
inimputables, esto quiere decir que
tienen alguna discapacidad mental.
Hemos entregado camas para Instituciones
que laboran con mujeres víctimas de
violencia y sus familias, lavadoras
para una casa hogar, salas para otra y
todo gracias a pegar la cara en el vidrio.
Así es como trabajamos; cada tres meses
elegimos una Institución, el día de hoy
estamos concluyendo en favor de "Fundación
Inclusión Autismo" y bueno, yo ya dije,
cómo hacemos para que la mujer se sienta
feliz, por qué creemos que
cuando una mujer se siente motivada,
se siente capaz de enseñar
o de aprender de otras
para sentirse empoderada, esta felicidad
que nos genera el dar, es más
bienaventurado que recibir, ese pan
que arrojas sobre las aguas, muy pronto
regresará a nosotros. Esta felicidad que
se genera en la mujer por ende se va a
contagiar en su familia y se verá
reflejada en la sociedad en la que vivimos
Nuevamente te invito a que mires a
la mujer que está a tu lado, yo ya te dije
qué hacemos para que nuestras mujeres
se sientan felices, mira a esa mujer y
comprometete hoy a hacer algo porque
ella, a través de ti, se sienta feliz.
Muchas gracias.